do you think there will be a day
when ai system
can't be denied
that it earned that nobel prize do you
think we will see that in 21st century
it depends what type of ais we end up
building right whether they're um
you know goal seeking agents who
specifies the goals
uh who comes up with the hypotheses who
you know who determines which problems
to tackle right so i think tweets about
it announcement yes so let's announce
the results exactly as part of it um so
i think right now of course it's it's
it's it's amazing human ingenuity that's
behind these systems and then the system
in my opinion is just a tool you know it
would be a bit like saying with galileo
and his telescope you know the ingenuity
the the credit should go to the
telescope i mean it's clearly galileo
building the tool which he then uses
so i still see that in the same way
today even though these tools learn for
themselves um they are i think of i
think of things like alpha fold and that
the things we're building as the
ultimate tools for science and for
acquiring new knowledge to help us as
scientists acquire new knowledge i think
one day there will come a point where
an ai system may solve or come up with
something like general relativity of its
own bat not just by
averaging everything on the internet or
averaging everything on pubmed
although that would be interesting to
see what that would come up with
um so that to me is a bit like our
earlier debate about creativity you know
inventing go rather than just coming up
with a good go move
and um so i think uh solving i think to
to you know if we wanted to give it the
credit of like a nobel type of thing
then it would need to vent go uh and
sort of invent that new conjecture out
of the blue um rather than being
specified by the the human scientists or
the human creators so i think right now
that's it's definitely just a tool
although it is interesting how far you
get by averaging everything on the
internet like you said because you know
a lot of people do see science as you're
always standing on the shoulders of
giants and
the question is how much are you really
reaching
up above the shoulders of giants maybe
it's just assimilating different kinds
of
results of the past
with ultimately this new perspective
that gives you this breakthrough idea
but that idea may not be
novel in the way that we can't be
already discovered in the internet maybe
the nobel prizes
of the next 100 years are already all
there on the internet to be discovered
they they could be they could be i mean
i think um
this is one of the big mysteries i think
is that uh uh i i first of all i believe
a lot of the big new breakthroughs that
are going to come in the next few
decades and even in the last decade are
going to come at the intersection
between different subject areas where um
there'll be some new connection that's
found between what seemingly with
disparate areas and and one can even
think of deep mind as as i said earlier
as a sort of interdisciplinary between
neuroscience ideas and ai engineering
ideas uh originally and so um so i think
there's that and then one of the things
we can't imagine today is and one of the
reasons i think people we were so
surprised by how well large models
worked is that actually
it's very hard for our human minds our
limited human minds to understand what
it would be like to read the whole
internet right i think we can do a
thought experiment and i used to do this
of like well what if i read the whole of
wikipedia uh what would i know and i
think our minds can just about
comprehend maybe what that would be like
but the whole internet is beyond
comprehension so i think we just don't
understand what it would be like to be
able to hold all of that in mind
potentially right and then
active at once and then maybe what are
the connections that are available there
so i think no doubt there are huge
things to be discovered just like that
but i do think there is this other type
of creativity of true spark of new
knowledge new idea never thought before
about can't be average from things that
are known um that really of course
everything come you know nobody creates
in a vacuum so there must be clues
somewhere but just a unique way of
putting those things together i think
some of the greater scientists in
history have displayed that i would say
although it's very hard to know going
back to their time what was exactly
known uh when they came up with those
things although
you're making me really think because
just the thought experiment of deeply
knowing a hundred wikipedia pages
i don't think i can um
i've been really impressed by wikipedia
for for technical topics yeah so if you
know a hundred pages or a thousand pages
i don't think who can visual truly
comprehend what's
what kind of intelligence that is that's
a pretty powerful intelligence if you
know how to use that and integrate that
information correctly yes i think you
can go really far yeah you can probably
construct thought experiments based on
that
like simulate different ideas so if this
is true let me run this thought
experiment then maybe this is true it's
not really invention it's like just
taking literally the knowledge and using
it to construct a very basic simulation
of the world i mean some argue it's
romantic in part but einstein would do
the same kind of things with a thought
experiment yeah one could imagine doing
that systematically across millions of
wikipedia pages plus pubmed all these
things i think there are
many many things to be discovered like
that they're hugely useful you know you
could imagine and i want us to do some
of these things in material science like
room temperature superconductors or
something on my list one day i'd like to
like you know have an ai system to help
build better optimized batteries all of
these sort of mechanical things my
system i think a systematic sort of
search could be uh
guided by a model could be um could be
extremely powerful
you